es ist vielleicht die eine heitere
Stunde in der Woche des Robert Habeck
die 30 Jahrfeier zum Zusammenschluss von
Bündnis 90 und den Grünen Lachen Witze
Anekdoten gestern Abend in Leipzig und
einmal nicht an filzvorwürfe und
Wärmepumpen denken
[Musik]
Harbeck und seine grünen stehen unter
Druck die Umfragen fallen die Fragen
nach der Umsetzung der Grünen wärmewende
werden drängender dabei ist dem Minister
die Herausforderung schon sehr bewusst
bei der Grünen Wärme für alle reden wir
am Montag mit 80 Millionen Bundesbürgern
und 40 Millionen Haushalten und die
Fragen und die unterschiedlichen
Ausgangslagen sind so unterschiedlich
wie ungefähr 40 Millionen Menschen
unterschiedliche Leben führen doch
Harbeck und seinen Master meint Patrick
reichen haben den Eindruck hinterlassen
dass sie auf 40 Millionen
unterschiedliche Leben nur eine Antwort
haben ab 2024 wird der Einbau von
Gasheizung quasi verboten die Fragen
nach der Verfügbarkeit der Förderung
oder der gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz
bleiben weitgehend unbeantwortet
[Musik]
Druck statt Mitnahme prägen das zentrale
politische Projekt der Grünen Robert
Habeck geht den Fragen danach aus dem
Weg breite Schultern setzen dies mit
unter durch die verwandtenaffäre von
Patrick reichen macht es noch
unangenehmer der sonst so eloquent der
Kommunikator scheint davon zu laufen
[Musik]
da ist nicht mehr viel von der
Angriffslust der Vision einer Klimawende
wie sie noch im Wahlkampf von vielen
geteilt wurde so mancher Satz der damals
selbstbewusst beklatscht wird wirkt
heute fast arrogant was wir aber nicht
mehr zulassen werden ist kritisiert
zu teilen die nichts auf der Pfanne
haben das Schwinden der Vertrauen in die
Grünen ist in Zahlen ablesbar in Bremen
wird in einer Woche gewählt drei
Bundesminister darunter die
Umweltministerin hat die Partei diese
Woche aufgeboten die scheinen den
Abwärtstrend aber gerade zum
mitzubringen
von 19 Prozent noch Anfang März ist die
Partei auf 13% abgestürzt deutlich unter
die 17 Prozent der letzten Wahl ich
nehme die Diskussion schon so war dass
sehr grundsätzlich in Frage gestellt
wird ob wir mit Klimaschutz schnell
vorankommen sollen oder ob wir noch 20
Jahre Zeit haben so wie Friedrich Merz
von der CDU das formuliert hat was für
bei vielen anderen Parteien gerade
erleben ist zwar ein bekennendes dafür
zu sagen klar wir brauchen Klimaschutz
aber diejenigen die jetzt das aktuelle
Gesetz kritisieren die legen ja keinen
Alternativvorschlag vor wie ist denn
dann gehen könnte und dann kommt man am
Ende eben zu keinem Klimaschutz die
anderen die Gegner des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes das sind auch FDP und
SPD die Liberalen diffamieren das
Projekt als heizungsverbotsgesetz die
SPD will massive Änderungen bei der
Förderung
die Grünen haben sich eingerichtet in
ihrer Wagenburg die den Blick auf eigene
Defizite verstellt
ernsthaft darüber nachdenken ob wir eine
Politik fortsetzen als Koalition wo man
glaubt man habe schon ein politischen
Erfolg erreicht wenn man den
Koalitionspartner ausgebremst hat
Selbstkritik das Einräumen von Defiziten
Distanz zu seinem strauchelnden
Staatssekretär Robert Habeck vermeidet
all das als er nicht weglaufen kann auf
einer eigenen Pressekonferenz am Ende
der Woche ringt sich der sonst so
redegewandte Minister ein paar trotzige
Worte ab angefasst und genervt
meine persönlichen Umfragewerte stehen
überhaupt nicht zu Debatte ist nicht das
worauf ich gucke sondern auf das was
passiert im Haus in einem Staatsamt und
da möchte ich gerne so agieren da wo
Fehler passieren soll man sie nicht
vernuscheln vertuscheln oder
wegreden der Superstar der Grünen
erleidet und seine Partei an ihm
und bei mir im Studio ist jetzt der
kurvorsitzende der Grünen Omid Nuri
Porsche guten Abend schönen guten Abend
Henry pur Robert Habeck steht in dieser
Woche massiv in der Kritik für seinen
Umgang mit seinem Staatssekretär Patrick
reichen finden Sie die Entscheidung kein
reichen im Amt zu lassen richtig
reichen hat einen Fehler gemacht
ist hatte eingeräumt der Fehler war bei
der Besetzung der Spitze der Energie
Netzagentur und ist jetzt ab korrigiert
worden und jetzt gilt es dass die großen
Aufgaben in diesem Land und die
allergrößten liegen bei
Robert habe auf dem Schreibtisch jetzt
einfach weiter fortgesetzt werden und
angegangen werden ihre Kofler sitzende
Ricarda lang war heute bei der ARD beim
Bericht aus Berlin und hat gesagt die
Grünen brauchen Glaubwürdigkeit für die
anstehenden Aufgaben ist denn Patrick
reichen nach diesen intransparenten
personalmanöver noch glaubwürdig er hat
einen Fehler gemacht in der eingeräumt
hat und der korrigiert worden ist wir
reden nicht über systematische
Netzwerke wie wir sie kennen aus der
maskenaffäre wie wir sie kennen aus der
Moskau connection und vielen anderen
Parteien das ist richtig und hat die
Fehler jetzt hat einen Fehler gemacht
und der ist ganz viel ist ja noch drauf
gepackt worden was einfach gar nicht
damit zu tun hat wenn ich jetzt lese er
seit der gefährlichste Mann Deutschlands
wenn ich jetzt lese das
führende Klimaforscher die einem
Öko-Institut arbeiten weil jemand anders
dort arbeitet der was mit Patrick
reichen zu tun hat jetzt plötzlich in
den Fadenkreuz geraten dann wird es ein
bisschen bunt und ein bisschen wild dass
er ein Fehler gemacht hat wenn ich gut
und jetzt ist der korrigiert worden der
Fehler also die Familie Netzwerke lese
ich daraus finden Sie grundsätzlich
nicht problematisch
noch mal hier klarstellen wir sind die
Grünen wir werden mit anderen Maßstäben
tatsächlich auch bemessen und das ist
auch gut so das ist auch richtig so und
wir wollen auch nicht behandelt werden
wie die CSU wenn die Frau von einem
Staatssekretär tatsächlich ein Auftrag
bekommt von einem Ministerium für eine
Studie und der Minister ist Peter
Altmaier und sie macht diese Studie
fertig dann weiß ich jetzt nicht was das
Problem ist jetzt sind wir bei Ihnen bei
den Grünen und es entsteht der Eindruck
durch diese Verflechtungen dass die
Grünen nicht die besten Leute für eine
Aufgabe und für wichtige
transformationsprojekte suchen sondern
möglicherweise nur die besten Leute aus
der Verwandtschaft und der Bekanntschaft
wie wollen Sie denn diesen Eindruck
entkräften in dem ich zu ihnen komme und
beispielsweise darstelle dass die Frau
von Patrick reichen eine Studie gemacht
hat für das Wirtschaftsministerium von
Peter Altmaier also in der
Vorgängerregierung ist das Auftrag
erteilt worden und dementsprechend muss
man sehr präzise bleiben bei den Fehlern
gemacht worden sind und das ist ein
Fehler gemacht worden weil bei der
Dehner also bei der energienetzagentur
und niemand hat den Interesse daran dass
Weg zu reden aber der Rest an an Dingen
die da jetzt auf dem Tisch gepackt haben
sind teilweise ein bisschen befremd dann
schauen wir auf Ihre Gesamtbilanz
momentan wie sie bei den Menschen
ankommen in den Umfragen verlieren sie
derzeit Robert hat im Deutschlandfunk
Interview der Woche dazu gesagt die
Umfragen gehen rauf und runter und man
solle nicht seine Politik daran
orientieren zieht er denn mit dieser
Haltung die Grünen runter nein es geht
darum dass dieses Land eine eine ein
Leid hat ein leiden hatten das Leiden
ist das ganz vieles in den letzten
Jahren einfach nicht gemacht worden ist
was notwendig war zu viele Leute in
Verantwortung haben auf ihre
Umfragewerte geschaut auf ihre
Popularitätswerte geschaut und
dementsprechend das Land nicht
krisenfest gemacht und wir machen das
gerade wir holen auch teilweise Dinge
nach die andere einfach nicht gemacht
haben und am Ende die würden wir daran
bemessen ob wir geliefert haben oder
nicht einen Preis dafür wenn wir nach
Bremen schauen wir haben die Zahlen
gerade gesehen das war meine grünen
Hochburg und da haben sie massiv
verloren da ist es runtergegangen auf
13% in den Umfragen wie klug ist es denn
an einer Energie und Klimapolitik zu
festzuhalten die die Leute
offensichtlich nicht mitnehmen noch ein
Unfall wird aus Bremen benennen darf die
Hälfte der Leute gar nicht entschieden
wie sie wählen werden in Bremen wir
werden sehen wie die Wahlergebnisse sind
gewinnen wenn sie festhalten
deshalb machen wir noch eine Woche
Wahlkampf ich sehe gerade
die Waldbrände in den Kanada mitten im
Mai wir haben
übelste Dürre mit mittlerweile jetzt
mitten im Mai in Thailand gab es letztes
in Spanien gibt es gab es im April Orte
die mussten Wasser tatsächlich
rationieren wir können immer so tun als
wäre die nächste Umfrage relevant dann
werden wir aber kein Klimaschutz machen
und dafür sind wir nicht angetreten ich
will aber nur auf eines hinweisen wenn
wir gute in den Umfragen heißt es ihr
seid ja immer gut in Umfragen gewinnt
keine Wahl wir wollen Wein gewinnen
keine Unfall sagt der Grünen Vorsitzende
um mich nur reporär herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch